thank you sing hi thank you that's your
last name yeah you're not mexican
yeah oh i [ __ ] up my bad you're a
[ __ ] idiot i'm a [ __ ] idiot
what are you do you actually think
because i haven't gotten that since
texas
[Laughter]
this is a real story i know what you are
dude this is a real story my my
principal in middle school because i
used to be fatter
and lighter my principal in middle
school every time he saw me used to say
ola amigo like he really thought he was
bonding
everybody thought i was mexican mexicans
would be like what's avatar and i'd be
like nah yeah they'll say this so he got
that light eyes yeah yeah yeah but i
think i grew into my indian-ness which i
don't know
you know it's like it's funny you grew
up in texas then yeah so you must have
had a little bit of a lot of little
micro aggressions when it comes to race
i know macro or nothing i think really
nothing i'm sure but i didn't notice
that
oh really saying macro what macro or
nothing no no there's a micro and macro
agreement but he's only gotten the macro
oh you've got like what is a macro
aggression you've gotten race wise this
was a funny one i can say it because
it's actually funny and i can look back
at that
on september 11th
before anybody knew what was happening i
i remember watching and i had seen a
documentary on al qaeda like a couple
years ago in like geography or something
and i was like oh [ __ ] it was probably
that guy and i didn't say a word because
i was like this is gonna be bad for me i
was one of two brown kids in my school i
think there was a pakistani kid in me
and that was it yeah and then no white
kids have figured it out yet none of
these country [ __ ] i figured it
out yet but then as i'm walking down the
halls two mexican football players put
my hands behind my back and walk me down
the hallways going we got him
don't worry everybody as we go yeah
so funny that's like very funny it's
very funny there was other stuff that
was like not like my life was threatened
or anything but it hurt my feelings so i
don't talk about as much but that's when
you've pulled the mexican card
at 9 11 i would have turned mexican that
day like when i did when i was shooting
pineapple express i had one line
and that's when uh
that's when that uh
you aren't shooting pineapple express if
you have one line
you can't say when i was shooting you
tell them two hours i was at on set no
no no no no bro
i was an expert so they had me like in
long shots yeah right so you know come
on don't [ __ ] haze me man nah dude i
love you i love you too i used to see
you at the comedy store you don't know
me but i would always see you are you
intimidated to talk to you no it's so
funny
i remember performing and seeing you in
the audience really yeah and go is that
akash
[ __ ] anyone let me finish my so when
i was at pineapple express
that's when that crazy that day you hung
out on set that going korea
akash that crazy korean dude shot up
virginia tech oh right so that's not
like our 911 really but it's like yeah
it felt like oh i'm chinese yeah i mean
like i had to like
change you know i mean for a couple of
years you should have gone filipino
chinese after 9 11 that's when i became
kalylah i was highly loving
so we all had to change and adjust right
baby you had to adjust 100
so let me ask you do you i don't know
anything about you i just need to ask
you some questions i know a little bit
about you personally you know andrew got
you into rehab i'm glad that happened uh
he's going to be at your wedding
i think that's really sweet that your
friendship is that close
do that for him and uh you know it's so
funny i'm just happy he's an [ __ ]
like him strong team